the people who run zimbabwe
are sending its citizens a powerful
message
descent in any form will not be
tolerated
here residents of a township in the
capital harare
were beaten for sitting outside
the government of emerson managua has
shut the country down
after opposition groups called for
protests against corruption
and economic mismanagement but the
president saw it differently
accusing critics of insurrection
however a small number did take to the
streets and dusty tracks
and there were some who were brave
enough to show their faces
like award-winning author sitsi
dungarenga
she was bundled into a police truck by
armed officers
shortly after this photo was taken
our team caught up with the writer who's
been nominated for this year's booker
prize
after she was released on bail and she
told us
she has the constitutional right to
fight for change
i feel that probably all zimbabweans
want a better life for all zimbabweans
and the people who live here
and i think that that's a very right
motive to have it's a good thing to live
by
and to work for
dozens of government critics have been
arrested including the spokesperson of
the main opposition party
the mdc right police have arrived
broadcast her own arrest before being
charged with
inciting public violence and breaching
the rules on
covet 19. it's an indictment on who
we've become as a society in zimbabwe
that people cannot step outside their
homes
and protest um against all the
injustices that we see
the fact that corruption is killing us
the fact that we've got a hunger crisis
the fact that our public health system
is on its knees
if we're criminalizing the very fact of
speaking out
that cannot be the zimbabwe that we're
after it means we've got a very long way
to go
emerson manning took power in 2017
promising economic growth and
world-class public services
but he's fast becoming associated with
the worst practices of his predecessor
the long-time dictator robert mugabe
is all over if you could just throw this
up
a pattern of arbitrary arrests and
abductions
is now well established last year we
interviewed union leader albert
massouera
who said he was kidnapped and beaten by
agents of the state
when he called for an increase in
teachers pay
it seems acts of protest have been
officially banned
by a paranoid government determined to
suppress
dissent journalist hopewell chinono
was arrested after revealing kickbacks
in the health department
but his voice and those of many others
will not be silenced
john sparks sky news